we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p we talked
earlier about the new book
a warning written by an anonymous trump
staffer here is speculation about who
that staffer might be hey David this is
Dave from California yes do you know
that book written by that author called
anonymous rumor has it the authors Kelly
Conway can you confirm or deny that
rumor right I cannot confirm or deny but
the you know the interesting I've heard
that speculation as well and I think
part of it is it's widely known that
Kellyanne Conway's husband George Conway
is a major critic of the President of
the United States Donald Trump how could
it be that Kellyanne Conway is such a
brown-nosing trump advisor and she's
married to a guy who is so publicly an
antagonize ur an antagonist of Donald
Trump and one of the speculations is
that behind the scenes Kellyanne Conway
is disgusted with Donald Trump much like
her husband and that she is the
anonymous person who wrote the letter in
the New York Times the op-ed in The New
York Times last year and that she is the
author of the book about the Trump White
House I have no idea certainly you can
frame up a scenario where it seems
logical but I don't know anything else
about it we've got a great bonus show
for you today we will talk about the
resignation of the Bolivian President
Evo Morales we will also talk about why
people are left or right handed and
whether that is changing over time I am
a lefty myself politically and in the
literal sense and also I had a really
weird ghost text message that a friend
of mine received from me a few days ago
and we have figured out what it is that
caused it and apparently this confused
thousands of people all of these stories
and more on the bonus show get instant
access by becoming a member at join
pakman.com or by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show